you
hello everybody welcome to the third
Bitcoin trading video in this video
we're going to be focusing on discerning
whether or not it even makes sense to
try to trade Bitcoin so to do this we're
going to need some sample files of
trading history
luckily unlike the stock market pricing
data is at the moment completely free in
public so all transaction history will
always be free right that's always going
to be like a matter of public record but
the pricing data is just at the whim of
the exchange to offer it and so it just
so happens that I don't know of any
single major exchange that does not
offer their pricing data in 100% form
for free so that's kind of cool that
everyone is free at the moment they eat
in and then at least from what I found
Mount GOx and btc-e
both offer real-time AP is they're not
streaming API so you have to like
continue hitting them very frequently
which doesn't make much sense to me I
don't know why they wouldn't offer
streaming API instead but that's just
the way it is but the nice thing about
it though is that as someone that's
interested in possibly even trading in
the real stock market you can test your
skills on this market and you have
basically everything you could ever wish
for in the stock market that you'd have
to pay for you get it all here free so
you can really test your skills and
decide whether or not you really want to
even bother doing this kind of thing in
the real stock market because really
everything is on your side at the moment
so um let's see so for me I didn't
really have a hard time finding any
historical data uh I didn't find it on
their actual like mount GOx or BTC EES
website I'm sure it's there somewhere I
just couldn't find it the first place I
found it was at another website that
offers a bunch of the data so what I'll
go ahead and do is I'll put the link in
the description for this data but let me
just show you guys now um and in fact
I'll show you guys the website first
is of course I'm having a hard time even
getting does the problem is like the
website could eventually go down here
you go I finally got to it so I'll drag
it over here so this is the website here
before we get going I would just like to
point out that I think that at least on
the last video these two prices Mount
Cox and btc-e were actually converging
and then yesterday actually btc-e was
higher than Mount Cox by like ten
dollars or something whatever I was
watching I'm sure it hit like a peak of
20 bucks or something so that was kind
of interesting but also if you notice
right now we've got a huge gap now in
price we're talking about $50 gap in
price so that's kind of interesting to
see as well that's the largest gap I've
seen in a long time so I might even be
largest have I've ever seen so anyway
that's pretty interesting select right
now you can easily engage in some
arbitrage here selling manga acts buying
btc-e selling manga expecting PGCE with
relatively a safe idea that you're gonna
make money right now it's going up and
the most it's even gone like here we've
gone from 9:30 to 900 still a twenty
dollar gap even if you screwed up really
badly you still would have made money
aren't using arbitrage so pretty
interesting that's probably what's
helping it's not it's kind of like a
self-fulfilling prophecy here because as
that gap gets bigger people are going to
continue buying on btc-e and selling
here so it'll be interesting to see this
gap if it closes up or what but again
people are having a hard time getting
their money out of mount GOx so so
really the only way out of mount GOx is
to buy bitcoin on mount GOx and then
transfer it somewhere else so anyway if
anything we should really see this gap
continuously kind of get wider and btc-e
not rise as fast as mount GOx but anyway
it'll be interesting to see this pant
play out if this gap gets even bigger so
I
anyway I just wanted to point out that
gap since it's a massive gap so
obviously there is money to be made in
arbitrage and eventually we will start
talking about that as well but that's
kind of a more complicated process
because you've got a transfer you've got
to consider all of the fees both in the
transfer and the buy and sell in each
exchange at time and all of this so you
have to decide whether or not it's
actually where their time is a $50 gap
is actually kind of rare but obviously
if you saw it you might as well take
advantage so anyway back to what we were
talking about just trying to figure out
it fit this little window on our screen
here I'll do this so the website is
Bitcoin charts com
and here you can find a bunch of stuff
they even have their own API that you
can check out um and they also that's
kind of interesting they have like
buildable pools cuz you get mine in a
pool I've never even noticed this down
here right um anyway coming back up here
let's uh let's look at we want to go to
I don't even know how to get there cuz I
got I just use their little link I'm not
really sure the easiest way to get to
the earth in me Bitcoin we're looking
for their API basically let's do markets
API down at the bottom and you can
connect to their API but they asked you
not to query more often than every 15
minutes so I don't know why anyone would
you share API uh but they I guess they
have open high/low close so maybe if you
wanted someone to do that for you I
don't know anyway but what we're
interested in is the historical data now
because what we want to know is do we
even want to bother with an API what we
would need to do first is check out all
the historical data and decide whether
or not we can actually think up a
trading system that would even you know
make sense up till this point because
right now that the market has actually
been quite volatile for the past couple
days so we'd want to know if this was
even worth it so so the first thing we
want to do is we want to come over to
Bitcoin charts now so for at least for
this video what I'm going to do is I'm
going to use the USD prices
now all of these prices are going to be
fairly similar to each other and if
you'll notice this is just a huge list
of all of the exchanges and their rates
right so you've got I don't even know
this exchange to be honest you got b7
USD BC I don't even see a USD from these
folks but BC em and so on
and anyway what we're going to be
interested in is mostly BTC USD simply
for the fact that it looks like their
data is just more higher granularity
kind of data so like Mount GOx for
example seems to be more volatile but
their API that we can actually plug into
isn't as good as BTC - II so my thinking
is that I'd rather develop something
that works best on btc-e because that's
the one that's going to give me the most
reliable data because I know the volume
on Mount GOx has to be better than what
it's showing me right now but I'm not
seeing it whereas here actually a good
way to do it would be to compare
possibly the size of the file I think
the start point would be pretty close so
24:14 is that one and then we could go
mount GOx where the heck is USD you
blind man so it looks like they actually
have more data but I think Mount GOx
probably started earlier it's hard to
say and in the beginning of Bitcoin the
trade volume for Bitcoin was way higher
as you'll see we'll actually plot it up
but anyway while you're here what you're
going to want to download at least for
us what we're going to do is we're going
to pin these two against each other
because we're going to post you know we
want to consider mount GOx but again
it's just the API from BTC ES just
definitely superior because like I said
I'm sure the volume is higher so that
you're missing a lot of data from mount
GOx whereas the btc-e api I just think
is better so if we can I'd rather
develop something for btc-e and trade
just btc-e
but for the purposes of arbitrage it
would make sense to maybe check out a
lot of these other guys and see if you
can't find a ratio and all that and so
we'll probably be talking about some of
that later on down the road but for now
at least download a btc-e
and download this USD file so it's going
to be a pretty big file so I'm going to
go ahead and cut the video here while
I'm downloading this file and then you
you as well download btc-e if you want
you could also go ahead and pick up the
mount GOx USD or any of the other ones
all of the other exchanges besides
pretty much btc-e mount GOx the file
sizes are fairly small for USD and
really any other amount like this one
looks big but it's mount GOx of course
and as we scroll down the only other one
that's kind of big is this one yeah so
anyway go ahead and download this files
and then we'll continue talking in the
next video we'll actually plot these
files up and check out what we're
looking at and the first thing that
we'll do is we'll compare with like RSI
and and see if there's anything there
like I've got RSI here for the most part
it seems like it's it's somewhat correct
except for like here it would have told
us to sell
and instead it's still continued to
drift up but this these prices here this
is really like a I don't know an hour
and a half or so of data most like more
like an hour and 45 yeah about an hour
45 so it's you know to small amount of
data to really decide whether or not
this that would be a trading system
think you should trade on right so so
what we want to know is is we want to
really back test this data so that's
what we'll be doing in the next videos
is back testing the data we'll make a
basic chart again if you guys want to
see how to make a chart like this one uh
you can let me know in the comments
there I mean I've got tutorials on how
to make charts just like this all of the
indicators are covered so really
everything is covered so I'm not sure if
it would be a waste of you guys is time
for me to put up a tutorial video on it
so if you guys really want to see it I
have no problem making one for it but if
not then don't worry about it so anyways
download those files and as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions also if you do
like my videos I've got a Bitcoin
address that you can donate any amount
of Bitcoin even if it's like point zero
zero zero zero one that would be nice
I'd like to start developing just a
straight up like algo trading system but
you need Bitcoin for that so anyway if
you guys want to see something like that
toss me some bitcoins and we'll see what
we can make as always thanks for
watching